OF WAR.
THIS ONE INVOLVING AMERICA
VERSUS ITS ALLIES.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT.
>> TO HEAR TRUMP TELL IT, TRADE
WARS ARE EASY TO WIN.
OTHERS BELIEVE THEY'RE BEST
AVOID.
>> IN THE OVAL OFFICE TODAY
WITH ISRAEL'S PRIME MINISTER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS STANDING HIS
GROUND ON IMPOSING TARIFFS.
>> WE'RE NOT BACKING DOWN.
WE LOST 800 BILLION A YEAR ON
TRADE.
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE GOT TO GET IT BACK.
>> OPPOSITION TO THE PLAN IS
GROWING.
TODAY PAUL RYAN VOICED HIS
CONCERN TO THE STATEMENT FROM
HIS PRESS AIDE SAYING, WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF A TRADE WAR AND ARE URGING
THE WHITE HOUSE TO NOT ADVANCE
WITH THIS PLAN.
THE TAX REFORM PLAN BOOSTED THE
ECONOMY AND WE DON'T WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE THOSE GAINS.
>> WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE SPEAKER.
WE DON'T AGREE ON EVERYTHING.
>> TRUMP DENIED A TRADE WAR.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'LL HAVE A
TRADE WAR.
>> HE WARNED AMERICANS TRADING
PARTNERS, HE WOULD PUNITIVE
ACTION.
>> IF THEY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING, WE'LL TAX THEIR CARS
THAT THEY SEND IN HERE LIKE
WATER.
>> THE PRESIDENT APPEARED TO
GIVE AMERICA'S CLOSEST NEIGHBORS
A POSSIBLE OUT.
NAFTA WHICH IS UNDER
RENEGOTIATION RIGHT NOW HAS BEEN
A BAD DEAL FOR USA.
TARIFFS ON STEEL AND ALUMINUM
WILL ONLY COME OFF IF FAIR
AGREEMENT IS SIGNED.
BUSH EVENTUALLY DROPPED TARIFFS
AS A RESULT OF PUNISHING
RETALIATION FROM TRADE ALLIES.
BOLTON WITH THE BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE SAYS GOING THERE
AGAIN WOULD BE A BIG MISTAKE.
>> THIS WILL CAUSE HUGE DAMAGE
ACROSS BROAD SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY.
YOU MAY GET A LIT UP HELP TO THE
STEEL AND ALUMINUM INDUSTRIES.
YOU CAUSE DAMAGE ACROSS ANY
NUMBER OF DOWNSTREAM INDUSTRIES
AND ANY NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES
THAT EXPORT TO COUNTRIES THAT
ARE LIKELY TO RETALIATE.
>> IN HIS TALKS WITH PRIME
MINISTER NETANYAHU TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOCUSED ON TRADE
AND IRAN AND THE AGAIN STALLED
MIDDLE EAST PEACE PROCESS.
WHAT THEY WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
WAS MOVING THE EMBASSY TO
JERUSALEM IN MAY.
>> WE WERE DISCUSSING WHETHER
OR NOT TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
THEY PROMISED IT IN THEIR
CAMPAIGNS BUT NEVER WERE ABLE TO
DO WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE.
I WAS ABLE TO DO IT.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THIS WILL BE
REMEMBERED BY OUR PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE AGES.
HE WAS STUNNED BY THE PRICE TAG
HE RECENTLY RECEIVED FOR THE
EMBASSY MOVE.
OF MY DAVG
OF MY DAV
OF MY DES
OF MY DESK
OF MY DESK L
OF MY DESK LAS
OF MY DESK LAST
OF MY DESK LAST WE
OF MY DESK LAST WEEK
OF MY DESK LAST WEEK F